peut être
vous vous souvenez ton accordéon me fait
j'y vais si tu jouais plutôt de la
clarinette et maintenant c'est ça n'a
rien changé dit maman d'accordéon
maintenant c'est gautier qui fait vos
clips alors quel effet ça fait d'être
devenu une star débrancher après avoir
été critiqué il ya 20 ans par par
antoine et c'est à dire que critiquer
critiquer si tu es notre saison ça va
non ça va lui un tout petit peu moins
faim on savait serais parti mon dieu la
critique il faut la prendre il faut la
lire il faut la laisser de côté il faut
entreprendre non autorisation jour là
antoine et pu la lui un bien c est ce qu
on pourrait dire oui voyage
je pourrai dire que j'ai quand même
continué et te l'accordé on a toujours
marché
alors quand vous étiez petit voulais
être concertiste et puis c'est vos
parents qui vous ont dit finalement tu
devrais jouer de l'accordéon parce que
l'accordéon quand même dont on meurt pas
de faim quand on joue de l'accordéon là
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous donneriez la
moitié de votre carrière
d'accordéonistes pour une carrière de
concertiste et non je referais la même
chose vous referiez la même si seulement
la même chose c'est à dire que quand mes
parents m'ont demandé de laisser les
études classiques de continuer après le
conservatoire d'apprendre la porno mais
ce que j'ai pleuré pendant trois ans on
peut dire trois ans je ne pouvais visite
impossible d'entendre une notes de piano
à la radio car j'étais c'était un
effondrement
j'avais perdu un amour un amour très
cher et qui n'a jamais cru mourir
d'ailleurs qui est toujours dans mon
coeur c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
enregistrer un disque là mais justement
parlons-en oui vous saurez indice de
classe et même disque classique au piano
avec du bist du crâne à dos d'âne bénite
des études de 10 et à la cour d euros
dont l'autre facile à 2 506 scarlatti
qu'est ce qu'il y a un but d'atteindre
enfin c'est pareil quand on est habile
de ses doigts on veut jouer de
l'accordéon on peut jouer du piano
l'étape habile à dire sa demande le
travail intense
c'est une discipline que l'on doit
s'imposer une discipline je dirais
réduite à 50 60 % quand on est en amour
quand on fait les choses avec passion
avec amour
donc c'est un travail constant est ce
que je disais moi je travaille beaucoup
mais c'est vrai que j'aime bien mais
c'est d'imad site son travail c'est une
légende
et moi je connais des plus grands
travail mais ils donnent pas toujours
l'impression d'être arras et je connais
quelqu'un qui travaille au centre je
vais te coucher à 6 heures du matin des
épaississants km vous êtes là vous
sortez un livre c'est finalement sur ma
carrière c'est pas chic un format là ça
fait dix ans que l'on me demande s est
fâché car non annoncés chez petit pas
qui a tort oui c'est tellement de
travail intense donc
620 et la musique il ya une chose qui se
passait et il faut se remettre en
question tous les jours
tous les jours on ne sait jamais vous
avez le trac quand vous montez sur une
scène vous êtes toujours le trac
j'essaie de devait être cette trempe là
parce que si vous voulez si on me
demande de compter jusqu'à 2100 mhz
arrêté et c'est une image sur scène je
compte eux résistent à 100000 ouais
voilà alors donc le reste il faut jouer
toujours beaucoup plus forte du
programme que l'on exécute un public et
ça je pensais que un peu on peut
maîtriser pour maîtriser bien sûr
l'instrument et sa demande que tu ne
vises lesquelles on fait quand que le
trac quand vous avez un peu le trac vous
faites quoi bon une coupe de champagne
non et non non surtout pas surtout pas
sont pas alors je me posais une question
qui nous brûle les lèvres c'est que vous
avez joué dans une fête organisée par
couscous clan actuelle à la cartoucherie
avec mort et mory kante
est ce que c'est une prise de position
politique est-ce que vous est ce que
c'est une prise de position ont
finalement en faveur du mélange d
bien sûr vous savez que les musiciens
donne de l'amour
beaucoup d'amour on ne dirait pas un
musicien prendre vouloir tirer derrière
quant à nous c'est la poésie c'est un
travail bien sûr j'ai dû tout à l'heure
et lorsqu'on m'a proposé de faire cette
émission à la cartoucherie de vincennes
avec des moniteurs couleur mory kante
avec l'arabe et cetera
c'est une idée qui m'a séduite par ce
que je pense moi bien sûr
le musicien est là pour dire que l'on
peut s'attendre il n'y a pas que le
vicieux mais n'a pas renoncé non 20 le
logiciel est là pour tendre pour tendre
la main pour donner de dolly d'abord est
alors plus en plus ces soirées là et
nous vivions policiers ont pas alors
étant donné que ce litige deuil de
l'arpp indienne me dit je ne peux pas
enregistrés en
je ne veux pas jouer dans plusieurs tons
je peux jouer en mi bémol
j'avais beaucoup tes lorsque ce sera à
vous de vous exprimer je ferai passer
mon orchestre en mi bémol tout le monde
sûrs en mi bémol et vous pourrez vous
êtes sensibles et nous avons joué alors
finalement ça a été une improvisation
pendant les quatre heures de temps et
j'ai passé une soirée
je peux dire démarquera dans ma carrière
nous avons joué avec beaucoup d'amour
nous nous sommes relayés nous sommes
tendu la main
c'est quelque chose qui passe est
absolument au long du match de vous
faire plaisir ça de jacques devoir en
n&b turner aller jouer avec mory kante
avec des musiciens africains
arava très beau je trouve pas de pain
tellement bien de la musique et danse
joue très bien mais c'est pas ce qu'il
va donner à gc sion el merrikh aux leurs
si on pouvait parler delà de la
politique de la même façon elle se
colore ses extraordinaires pour dire que
ses jours lundi qu'ils avaient danielle
mitterrand est venu avec
avec l'appelant et qui ont trouvé cette
soirée disons 2
je m'excuse et mômes à fait
exceptionnelle puisque c'était tous les
sujets comme ça on en a parlé le désir
d'en faire une grosse soirée au mois
d'octobre avec plusieurs assauts nous
tendrons la main aux pour le faire voir
au monde que c'est l'amour qu'il faut
c'est d'amour
ces chaleurs chaleur humaine et est
importante on ne peut pas vivre son
amour on peut pas vivre sans l'amitié au
liban 1500 septembre et ça n'existe pas
c'est fondamental et j'étais très
heureux c'était je vous dise
j'ai été séduite et pas cette idée je le
referais avec un grand plaisir et vous
avez été élevé chez les bonnes soeurs
est ce que vous êtes toujours croyant je
suis croyante
ça se traduit comment vous faites une
prière à leur entrée sur scène non non
ce sera lui comment on n'a pas besoin de
fréquenter l'église a fait un bond c'est
moi qui le pense je juge peut-être une
erreur mais on peut très bien être
croire croyant on peut prier parti dont
je fais pas de frais hier une rentrée
mais je suis croyant je ne suis pas
pratiquante et parce que le temps va
n'empêche
mais il ya une forme si vous voulez des
pratiques dans la croyance
donc je pense que je n'ai peut-être pas
besoin d'aller à l'église tous les pôles
et dinan roland dumas croyants ou je
crois qu elques quelques existence de la
divinité ou à l'ordre des choses à
l'ordre du monde
oui je ne suis pas je suis pas forcément
engagée dans une religion
et je pense aussi qu'il ya un tronc
commun à toutes les religions oui je
suis cette forme dans la guinguette
c'est à dire la richesse l'humanité
voilà je suis vieux il n'y a pas
plusieurs guéguen acteurs et plusieurs
façons il arrivait y en a qu'un il ya
cette divinité et les deux unités qui
bien sûr je pense que on ne le peut pas
dire voilà c'est mon dieu je suis la
police que c'était sur un dossier non il
ya celle du maire s'interpréter de comme
vous voudrez pourriez-vous merci je suis
ravi de vous entendre dire les choses si
importante dans un endroit où on s'amuse
immersive dans un endroit
et
[Musique]
c
bon
allah
ma femme
omar
non sans mal
à
et
ou pas
[Musique]
à
m
c'est
jeannie longo
ou pas
[Musique]
alors une belle quels sont tes projets
pour 88 alors là j'ai dépensé un très
beau projet mais qui me permettra de
garder le secret parole du las les
patients dit le valais non dire à
personne annoncer ses taux non je ne
peux pas le dire ça je ne peux pas le
dire c'est quoi ta pas dire je vais me
déguiser un charlot ah bon je viens et
ça j'ai fait un numéro de music hall je
vais faire des points et ça a des
charlots qui sera de l'accord d'union tu
vois c'est bien alors ça se prépare
c'est en train de se voir s paris et
qu'est ce que tu souhaites au jour pour
l'année 80
alors moi ce que je souhaite vraiment
une chose très sincèrement je dirais
beaucoup d'amour
[Musique]
c'est tendre la main tous les enfants du
monde soit heureux
puis ce sourire que l'on s'amuse
énormément avec l'accordéon ou les
autres
c'est bon aussi
voilà beaucoup de défis merci van ryb
[Musique]
oui
mo
enfin
[Musique]
à
oh
ce sens
[Musique]
bon
non
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]